you've mentioned confidentiality
and privacy that you don't the parties
don't need to necessarily know private
data
in this interaction you talk about
confidentiality in the
in the white paper for chain link 2.0
can you talk more about how to achieve
confidentiality
in this process sure sure absolutely
um so i think you once again need to
think of the contract as existing in two
parts right you have the on-chain code
and then you have this off-chain system
called
the centralized oracle network so the
question is really
what portion of the contract should live
in what part
of these two systems right so
if you want to create transparency you
should put
more information on chain because that's
what blockchains are very good at
they're public transparent but they
don't necessarily have privacy well
those
you can see how those two things are a
little bit kind of um
completely uh diametrically opposed
right yes so
i i do i do think and i do see
blockchains working
on on-chain encrypted smart contracts
that's very inefficient it has a lot of
nuances around it
that i think will appear at some point i
think until it appears
you have an option of taking a part of
the computation
and putting it into the centralized
oracle network
we actually did an entire paper about
this that we presented at stanford
um in february of last year uh something
called mixicles
which basically talks about how you can
take an oracle network and you can put
a portion of the computation into the
oracle network
assuming that you're comfortable with
that limited set of nodes
knowing what the computation is and you
can actually provide additional
confidentiality through
special hardware called trusted
execution environments that you that all
those nodes are forced to run
so they won't even know what they're
operating and so
at the end of the day if you look at a
hybrid smart contract
as gaining functionality from its own
chain code and gaining other
functionality from its off-chain
decentralized oracle network component
you can place the part of the
computation that you would like to be
private
in the decentralized oracle network
because
you can control the set of nodes you can
control the committee of nodes
and you can require that they run
certain hardware
to keep the information private right so
you could basically make a derivative
that
or a binary option is the example used
in in the mix paper
where the payout happened on chain
but it was actually impossible to tell
what the outcome of the contract was
so the the outcome of the contract was
computed in the centralized oracle
network
and then there was a switch that that
triggered who received the payment
but from who from from the point of view
of analyzing the on-chain transactions
and seeing um who received
the payment or what the outcome of the
contract was you couldn't
you you couldn't derive that you
couldn't backward engineer what that was
but the users of that hybrid smart
contract
still had on-chain code that guaranteed
them
that as long as the decentralized oracle
network found a certain
outcome right determined a certain
outcome that the relevant user would get
paid
and there was still a place to put value
right
so there there is this kind of
fundamental tension
between confidentiality privacy which is
very important for many contracts which
is critical to many contracts
and the public and transparent nature of
blockchains
which i think eventually will be solved
through encrypted on-chain smart
contracts
that'll take some time i think that'll
take years in my opinion
and before we arrive there i think
people will put
the private portion into the centralized
oracle network
once again going back to what the
decentralized oracle networks do
they seek to provide these services
right so the ability to do
a privacy preserving computation is
perhaps a service
without which a certain type of contract
might never come into existence
in the form of an unchained hybrid smart
contract
and so this is once again what we see
the centralized oracle networks and
decentralized services doing
is providing people these tools and
building blocks
to compose you know like i'm i'm great
at making these derivatives contracts
but i can't make them
until unless i can retain the privacy of
them
and our goal is to provide the
infrastructure
that gives you as a developer and as a
creator of smart contracts that
capability
and what we've seen is that as we
provide that capability people create
more
which is also really the story of the
internet right the story of the internet
is
it was really tough to do e-commerce
while everything was in http
and credit cards were transmitted
publicly and so e-commerce was kind of
tough because how am i going to send my
credit card
over public unencrypted channels right
but the second https appears
e-commerce becomes a lot easier because
i can put in my credit card number and
it can be sent over an encrypted channel
and you know it's not at risk and so i
can participate in e-commerce as long as
i have a credit card
i i think those types and and i'm sure
that was unexpected
right i'm sure at the time that was an
unexpected outcome from from that
technology
and so i think this is why we sometimes
have this focus on privacy
because in our work with contracts and
their transition into this hybrid smart
contract form
we see a substantial amount of need for
privacy
as as an inherent property of of these
contracts
and it'll take a while before that's
possible to create the kind of
technology innovation required to do
that on chain
i know there's a few ideas that are
being floating about but so the
currently distributed oracle networks
provide that feature the
which is essential to many contracts
what brings to mind
in this whole space again it might be
outside of your
expertise but within the world which i'm
passionate about which is machine
learning
and it seems like very naturally because
current machine learning systems are
very data hungry
and much of the value mined by companies
in the digital space or from data they
often
want their data to maintain privacy
so you think about an autonomous vehicle
space tesla's collecting huge amount of
data
waymo is collecting huge amount of data
it seems like it could be very
beneficial to form contracts where one
could use the data from
the other in some kind of privacy
preserving way but also where
all the uses of data are codified
and you can exchange value cleanly you
know basically
contracts over data over um
machine learning systems use of
different data i don't know do you
do you talk to machine learning folks
that you use ideas of smart contracts or
is that from outside your interest
because it seems like exceptionally
applicable
set of when we talk about different
services that might be created
and revolutionized by smart especially
hybrid smart contracts
i think machine learning systems comes
to mind to me
in all industries i i don't know if
you've gotten a chance to interact with
those folks
with those services i i think i think
what you're talking about is more data
marketplaces in
in the data marketplace side of things
um
well this is actually once again very
applicable because there's a trust issue
at the end of the day let's say i'm
trying to sell you some data
you um don't know the quality of the
data so you don't know what you want to
pay for it
and i can't give you the data for you to
determine the quality because i've given
you the data
right guess what we need an autonomous
impartial agent we need an apart
impartial
uh computational kind of agent an
on-chain uh smart contract
with an oracle network to assess my data
to write to
to basically take random cross-section
samples of the data
assess it for quality assess it for
signal
from the algorithm you have which you
don't want to share with me
because you don't want to know the
algorithm you're working on right you
don't want me to know
what you want the data for so now the
autonomous agent
takes your algorithm keeping it private
from me and takes my data keeping it
private from you
assesses it on a random cross-section
sampling for quality of data
returns the scoring back to you allows
you to determine a price
and now you and now both you and me know
that we've arrived at a fair price
for the quality of my data for what you
want to do with it
and um that's once again from what i've
seen in the
in the data marketplaces which are full
of people who want that data for these
learning models often for financial
markets
often for for for for other reasons this
is their fundamental
problem which amazingly enough there's a
trust
issue that is is is getting solved and
i think you can see even on the face of
it once that trust issue is solved
uh those markets can work a lot better
right
i don't need to know your algorithm you
don't need to know my data we both know
that the autonomous agent
is not under either of our control and
gave us a fair assessment than a fair
price
and uh and that's it and we're all very
comfortable with um with that we
i could even make conditions that your
algorithm
isn't analyzing the data for something i
don't want you to analyze it for or
you can make conditions that the data
has to have you know any number of
properties
and and once again you haven't leaked
any signal to me and i haven't leaked
any
any data to you which is once again just
another type of trust issue that did all
of this solve so it's it's the same
pattern
if you work in this industry long enough
or if you really look at these use cases
long enough
you'll simply come to the question and
this is the useful question
um what is the trust issue this is
solving and then if you can get an
answer to that question on a
case-by-case basis
that's when you'll understand why
blockchains are relevant
and then once you do that with enough
use cases it becomes
you know becomes a little bit
mind-blowing
you